her ballet shoes are now far away from
the prestigious bolshoi top ballerina
olgas mirnova says she opposes the war
with every fiber of her soul she left
russia with a heavy heart when i think
that russia's
started to
to
start this war
it makes me ashamed of my country
because my country
i was always proud of some
culture and sports achievements
and it's true it's really a
rich culture
smirnova has been a star dancer at the
bolshoi since she joined the company
more than a decade ago in review she was
described as a rarity a ballerina whose
every movement feels luminously right
and true
when you could captivate audience with
beauty and movement it means
you can tell or you can deliver to them
messages and these messages of
love peace kindness hope
smirnova is one of many russians who
left after the invasion in ukraine but
her defection as one of her country's
top ballerinas touches the very heart of
its ballet culture while ballet has long
been seen as linking russia to the
outside world the departure of smirnova
and others brings back memories of the
cold war and fears that russia could be
increasingly isolated
after western governments imposed
sanctions on russia the dutch national
ballet decided to stop its collaboration
with state subsidized companies like the
marinski ballet and saint petersburg
ballet is not completely removed from
politics and has never been
art and politics do exist together in
the same world
and so we also have to take a stand and
it feels like we're going back in time
and that's a terribly sad thing because
there has always been cultural exchange
while the exchange has passed for now
russia continues to be present in
smyrnova's performances just a few weeks
after she left her country she starred
in raimonda a ballet first choreographed
in 1898 in saint petersburg
of course it's my it's my country and
i'm russian
but i prefer not not to live in the
country which
behave
in this way
but people i've
have a kind of fear
for example i think my colleagues
and
in
is the time when everyone needs to
needs to
the choice to make
their own choice and i made mine
smirnova says by denouncing the war she
risked a long prison term the dutch
audience applauded her not only for her
performance but also for her stance
against the war step fast in al jazeera
in amsterdam